so you just get into a brand new
relationship and you have this
overwhelmingly strong desire to cross
the line but where is the line
especially if you're wanting to do
things like God wants you to do it let's
usend a Teemo as he's going to share his
convictions when he was dating his wife
welcome everybody to LED live today
we're a bunch of men discussing
relationships we have Teo Hoffman in the
house welcome back Teemo thank you so
much if you guys haven't seen teemo's uh
video that we did with him he was a
German rock star and came out of that
and it works in Ministry now I think
it's truly an amazing story you will be
blessed if you listen to that story but
teemo's had a really interesting um
experience especially in your
relationship with the woman that God
gave you today I'm excited to talk about
this because I truly believe there's
many people who for whatever reason
didn't do life like the Bible wanted us
to do life and so you know I I think
we're going to be blessed by this
conversation I hope you guys are blessed
as well welcome Teemo thank you so much
for having me again I'm looking forward
for the discussion and I believe that's
a very important topic you know to dive
into what courtship really is what
dating is what is the difference because
I think that God wants us really to have
happy marriages wants us to experience
already a piece of heaven here on Earth
and uh so in that direction he has given
us clear guidelines in his word and
believe believe that if we prayerfully
follow these guidelines it would help us
to make the right choice and not finding
us in a situation where we might regret
or where it might be difficult you know
God can still bless even if quote
unquote the wrong Persons get got
together but it's of course CH more
challenging and we know that God wants
to prepare us for heaven wants to
prepare our characters and that's why I
believe he wants to uh yeah bring the
right person Our Lives you know I've
heard it said that a lot of people will
say marriage you don't get married to be
happy you get married to be
holy and and that's an interesting
concept because it's like if you're
looking for that other person to bring
you happiness what happens when the
second they stop bringing you happiness
so you know we get rubbed wrong often
God puts opposites together right
someone who is really good in this area
but not good in this area and then vice
versa because he's after our character
but I don't think that necessarily means
that you get married and then you're
miserable because God is making you holy
I think happiness comes that's a good
point that's a good point I'll give you
that you if it's holy first then it can
be happy okay but if it's all you know
if you're going to focus on the
happiness first then it may not be holy
thank you for that clarification yes
yeah don't want to give people the wrong
idea yeah sure thank you for that so I
want to go along a little bit about uh
my experience that I had to make these
points clear and uh we did another video
actually here together where we talked
about about you know masturbation and
these things and this was the kind of
experience that I had in the beginning
when it comes to sexuality I was in a
very young age you know that I was
introduced I was 5 years old when I was
introduced into
masturbation and um so I had not uh
really a Biblical upbringing that I was
introduced into these guidelines when it
comes to courtship and marriage so I was
though I was raised a Catholic but I
have NE never had really an idea about
these things and my mindset was quite
worldly I must say so I had to struggle
you know with these things people can
watch that presentation if they want in
that area how God really gave me Victory
it's an amazing
testimony uh because it was very strong
on me but um so in my upbringing I was I
guess like almost every person you know
in this world I had my desires and
interests and at the very young age had
a strong desire for like
um yeah I don't want to say maybe
sexuality in that way because I was too
young really to comp that yes yes but
you were fascinated yes I was fascinated
had definitely a desire you know to to
look at other girls and things like this
and uh in the very young age you know
got my girl my first girlfriends MH and
so I desired always to have like you
know or made the decision myself the
person that I wanted to have my life MH
and to to win a person uh was for me I
had this idea that um if I have like the
right image um if I'm you know looking
good and maybe being an interesting
person would be kind of easy for me to
get this or that you know girl so I
remember I was um and I shared this in
my testimony besides music I was also
very much into bodybuilding so I was
quite heavier than today and I was
always think you know if I'm just you
know if you get ripped you got to have
muscles cuz that's what girls want they
want muscles you need a sixpack yes
there was my idea so and then I had
situations it's funny today looking back
I remember was at a party and there was
this I always was like looking for the
most beautiful girl you know like in my
eyes and I I was not happy to have like
the the other girls I wanted to have her
mhm challenge yes and I remember and
this happened a few times to me I saw
this one when I was at this party and I
saw this this young lady and I was
thinking you know I I want to have her
attention and uh I didn't do really much
you know approaching her or saying much
to her I was kind of shy but I thought
okay you know maybe I'm I'm goodlook
enough that they that she might maybe
approach me ref Flex just right right to
the bathroom you know exactly
so and um I I was observing her and then
often times the same thing happened she
if she you know got in contact with
another man she went off with another
person and often times with a guy which
was like in my eyes like this you know
thin he's got nothing on me look how
much bigger I am exctly you know this is
what run through a man's mind I was
thinking he's so boring you look at him
and things like this
and I was so embarrassed I was like I
was so ashamed you know I was thinking
oh man and then I I went home and I
trained hard even in the middle of the
night you know things like this wasn't
always the situation but um often times
you know this happened to me and I was
kind of you know is weird why does it
not work out so well and once in a while
I had girlfriends and you know like even
one night St and things like this but it
was not working out like I was thinking
it should work out and so this kind of
mindset you know I was sh this in the
other presentation also you know into
pornography and all that kind of stuff
so my my understanding of sexuality was
really to wrap it up was kind of really
perverse you know so and um but I don't
want to go too much into detail I want
not to picture that too much um but so
this was that people understand you know
I had no idea about when we talk about
this later what courtship is MHM so I
was more kind kind of in that setting of
dating people which means there are not
much really rules to it or let me say
guidelines to it you know it's maybe
okay maybe you meet that person maybe
you go in a relationship or not it's not
really about thinking that you might
marry that person at the end right you
know you're just wanting company right
now yes exactly so you really want to
fulfill just your desires your what the
Bible says your lusts you know I think
you're bringing out something that's
really interesting though you're you're
pointing out that we often look at
relationship like I want something I
want something from this yeah not what
can I give to this person exactly
interesting exactly so um this was my my
mindset and then when by by God's grace
I came back to the faith um in
2010 um I really investigated into
whatever Bible topic and I also wanted
to know what is God's will in this area
and so um I had a strong desire still
you know for a relationship or for wife
so and um in that time I was still
struggling also with masturbation I
didn't um or I had not overcome it yet
to that point but when I came to Faith I
was very serious so I wanted to walk
with God I studied my Bible and I said
to the Lord okay I want to to marry
someone that is you know pleasing to you
and that we can relate to each other in
faith so it was clear to me I didn't
want to have a relationship with
whatever person that person needed to be
um not only a Christian person that
person needed to be really in the same
Faith so I started to understand that
that um you know the concept of amus 3:3
how can you know to walk together if
they're unequally yolked yeah so and
then I just converted and I found my
faith in Christ and then I I um was at
the
church service one day on the Sabbath
and there was this young lady she
stepped into the room I saw her and like
my you know mindset which was in the
world I saw her she was very beautiful
and I was thinking wow you know she is
like she got my attention immediately
and then we talked a little bit and then
I figured out that she just recently
came to the faith like I did and she was
just on fire for Christ like me you know
we both were like missioned and
completely into it and I was thinking
wow this is just you know God you're so
amazing you know you brought me back
from this worldly lifestyle you had so
much patience with me bringing me on
this path of peace and hope and desire
to work for you and now you fulfill even
that other strong desire and wish which
I have in my life with probably with
that person because it fitted like kind
of
perfectly and I was like man God is so
amazing what is the what is the Bible
verse that that if you something and God
will give you the desires of your heart
I think it's in the Psalms but any
you're talking yeah you know what I mean
it's like seek you first the kingdom of
God and all these things he'll add into
you exactly yeah so I was thinking you
know just this this walk with God is
overwhelming everything it seems to so
perfect so we got in touch with each
other and started a friendship we we
liked each other obviously and then even
other people observed us because they
saw us often time together and I must
say at this point that um I really tried
tried to reach out to her to approach
her very often like in My Own Strength I
will explain this a little bit later in
a second what I mean by that um but we
were often times together also often
times just by ourselves but even when
people saw us friends of us church
members um they even saw that we might
been a good match and they um encouraged
us you know to like sure go in that
direction it's a good sign yeah
so but in the same time I must say that
um some of our friends they meant it
well but I believe it was sometimes not
um even I must say
maybe helpful that they did this
encouragement uh because I believe they
did not really follow in some respect
what God has in mind when it comes to
courtship so because I mentioned we were
often times very close and spent time
together even alone often
times um which I believe distracts you
and um points more to or um focus more
On Emotion than really to what I
explained later a little bit more uh
when it comes to courtship um really to
search out the person so you connect on
a different level yeah how much time is
going by when you're meeting this person
and getting together and people are
seeing you at church is this like couple
months is it six
months I was actually immediately when I
met her the first time we constantly you
know went into the friendship just a
normal friendship and then we spent like
it happened very quickly yeah very
quickly very quickly exactly so you know
I was trying to spend much time with her
U we were both mission-minded and we did
even a lot of good things together you
know enjoyed each other's yes sharing
books on the street we did a lot of
mission work tried to invite people so
was nothing bad in that sense but I
really desired to be close to her I
guess um back then I desired even like
if I had had a chance I I I'd like to
you know to embrace her get somehow
physical you know in touch with her not
that I was and at this point I must say
I was convicted you know that sex is
something which belongs into the
marriage had I got this understanding at
this point already but I think if I
would had had a chance to for example to
kiss her MH I probably would have made
it so I was not yet completely on on the
path where I believe that God wants us
to
be um and then uh we both made it a
ition that we wanted to go to a mission
uh school so where we got trained in
medical missionary work and things like
this and it was funny when we got the
application for it so I wrote down my
information and then um there was a part
of at this application just some empty
lines where we could write something
that we we know was on our heart to
share with them so I wrote a kind of a
love letter you know in that application
when I look back in reading that today
was a kind of a love letter that I
really try to convince those people from
the mission school that they also you
know should invite her to become a
student at the school so but I mean they
allowed both of us to come but they
understood the UN the the guidelines
which God has and so three weeks in the
training the principal took me on the
walk and he said to me Teemo you know I
observe you with her and
you pretty much close to her and try you
know I see that you try to win her but
please Focus you know on on the training
here that year that you here that's a
special time that you have with Christ
grow in Christ and these things you know
are they will come later you know don't
don't get distracted by this that was
wise advice it was a very wise advice
but do you know how my response was
it'll be fine yeah I can say no I said
to him because sorry he said to me teimo
get this out of your head you will not
not marry her you know here in that time
you will not come close to her you know
get this out of your head then I looked
at him and I said you will
see so I mean this was not correct to
say but this was my response in that
situation because I was kind of offended
I felt that I or that they want to take
the control out of my hands because I
was not um I mean I was not ready yet to
to Really surrender this to God and say
though I was praying you know I said
Lord please you know if she is the right
one I was praying these kinds of prayers
but I can look back today and can say I
was not really ready to say um you know
you make the decision it was like lip
service like yes exactly I you're just
telling God what you want and trying to
get him to agree with what you have
already determined exactly you know it's
it's completely fair to say that God
doesn't want us to marry someone that we
could not love God doesn't want us to
marry someone that is not attracted to
us even you know that's important things
God loves Beauty right um he mentions it
quite a bit she was fair to look at you
know he's talking about Sarah and yeah
so it's it's not bad but like you said
Keith I was just determined to to win
her and although I was praying so and
then in that time while we were in the
mission school I made like I tried just
everything you know to get her attention
and she was though we were very close
she never really made that that kind of
Step that I felt like okay I ready now
to like really open up and ask her for
relationship um she's playing hard to
get yeah so and then it was almost like
to the end of our year um I was reading
a book which I can really recommend to
people it's the book Adventist home so
this book talks about relationship
courtship and these things and gives
very Vice counsel even when you are
married so I was reading that book I was
in a different place that
weekend and I was attending some
Evangelistic meetings in between I was
reading in the book for devotion and now
I came to this passage and I was reading
over it went to the next page and then
the Holy Spirit told me Timo go back to
the page before and read that again so I
went back I read it and then I'm
paraphrasing she is talking about uh a
young young man who is really dedicated
to God is willing to serve him with his
whole life but when it comes to the area
of of relationship he's just going his
own way MH so I read this and I was like
wow you know that's actually me I feel
like that I'm honest with God I want to
serve him I want to do my best for him
but um I really try now to reach her to
win her over in my own strength and not
allow him to really you know bring
things together MH because I was always
afraid that I will lose her somehow I
had situations that I was even like I
was expecting okay maybe today it will
happen and then it didn't happen and
then I was crying and I was I felt
miserable I was really I don't know you
had it all planned out yes but it's it's
not like you were asking God like is
this your plan yes exactly because it
looked so perfect friends of us were
telling us you know oh you guys you
match so perfectly you love Christ you
love Miss work everything fits seems to
fit fine MH but
then I I said to God while I was reading
this quote I said okay Lord I understand
we need to kind of um you know go more
on the distance and give it more room so
I went back to the Mission School I was
determined to look for her and tell her
though it was hard on me to do
that but um so I looked for her and then
I found her in the school and then
before I could open my mouth she said
Timo I need to talk to you I said okay I
have also something to share with you
but you first and then she said Timo I
was convicted this weekend that we are
too clothe with each other and I said
wow that's amazing you know because she
and I don't want to um like um blame her
but I believe that she also did not
really understand back then that she was
giving too much science as a woman
because you know we Men We act like you
know we see beauty or we we act on
things um that women can give man a sign
because they're spending a lot of time
giving attention and then we feel like
oh no she might be interested in me yes
and women they're very much attracted by
when you talk to them and spend time and
listening to them so that's kind of the
way how it normally works and she felt
con uh con convicted and then I sh said
with her what what happened to me which
and we saw God's leading in this and we
said okay we need to go more in the
distance so we did um for a time but
then you know my desires came back and
then I made up my mind I prayed and I
said you know I will just open up to her
today so I I approached her I said to
her you know this is my feelings for you
this and that and would you be willing
to go in a relationship with me and then
I was I was expecting that she would say
yes but she was so upset she was really
upset wow she was like she was not
expecting this at all this whole thing
was for her just a a friendship yeah and
I was like you know don't you see you
know so obvious we've done a lot of
talking together I'm doing everything
right yeah so you know I do all these
nice things to you I drive you here and
there and you know and not I didn't do
it to manipulate her I didn't really you
know because I was in love with her so
to say um did it out of free will but I
was really I man this was hard then
because then normally when we for
example after we had a we had lunch for
example we went on a digest of walk
outside of the school and you could go
to the left or the right when you
stepped out of the entrance and normally
we went always together and this time we
went out after lunch and then she said
to me okay today you go this way and I
go that way
that's a bad s yes yes so and I was
miserable you know I was really
miserable but then at the end of the
school year then she kind of opened up a
little bit and then she said maybe we
should try it and I was like happy you
know M so but then I got a request to go
to the US I came here and I did for a
few months some Mission work and so we
were kind of separated uh she felt like
this is a good thing to do God gives us
time to think about it when I came back
from the US I um approached her again
and in that time which I shared in my
testimony that people can watch I
started to have a plant-based store
where I was reaching out to people and
she became one of my
employees and um so I was thinking you
know now it's uh maybe time that we can
talk about this again but nothing really
happened from her side I felt like she
was not really into it so I was hesitant
to approach her
again and um but while we were working
and this is a good thing you know to do
to work with a person um I figured out
that we and I don't blame her I just say
that we both have a kind of different
approach when it comes to to work I
think so and uh she had different she
was thinking a little bit different how
to do things and I thought this is maybe
the best idea to do it but um so after
it took me actually 2 years while were
working together that I I thought that
um you know this is actually not a good
fit I still respected her I still you
know kind of loved her as a friend uh to
this very day and I I still like enjoy
her to have have her as a friend but um
like in German we have this expression
that you have like a a purple glasses on
and then we say rose-colored glasses
exactly we see hearts popping yes yeah
like this so this where you know God
took it away and I got kind of sober and
saw the situation different I was
thinking you know this is actually not
not fitting let's hang on that for a
second because I think this is where a
lot of people detour off of getting to
know somebody MH if you're emotionally
getting intertwined with somebody you're
kissing them you're having premarital
sex you're having all these things that
that are going to wrap you in it's very
difficult to see the person at that
Point yeah and God I I believe God
designed it like this because in your
first year of marriage right to seal the
deal he puts those rose-colored glasses
on and it's like you know your first
year of marriage man these people can do
no wrong I don't know about you but
that's how I viewed my wife perfect
literally perfect yeah and then the one
year mark comes up it's like Lord what'
you do to me why'd you give me this one
and and that is now you start to begin
to work on your character but we but we
need to seal together like that so when
you jump the gun and you you you bond
together like that and you don't see the
issues it can it can easily um you know
you don't you don't see through those
rosec colored glasses yeah I think for
us it was a little different we went
through all the hard stuff first while
we were dating oh okay and three and A2
years and then marriage was easy after
that because all the all the hard stuff
came first but it but what you're saying
you know it reminds me of the story in
the Bible I think really illustrates
what you're talking about well when
Samuel is going to Crown the king of
Israel the next king after Saul and he
goes to Jesse's house and he's going to
have the sacrifice and you know sit down
and have dinner with
everybody Jesse lines up all of his sons
and Samuel gets to the first one and
he's like I mean this guy looks like
Saul he's head and shoulders of
everybody is surely this is the next
king of Israel and it was all based on
appearance you know Samuel saw with
these outward eyes this description of
somebody who he thought man he's tall
he's stately he's good-look he looks
strong this guy would make a good King
and he gets down to the end and God is
like no to every single one of
them and then Samuel you know he's
finding himself in an awkward she's like
do you have any more kids like well yeah
we got the shepherd boy you know he's
out watching the sheep and he's like
well bring
him and he and then God's like no this
is the
one this is the one and you know
Samuel's looking at him the Bible gives
a description you know David's young
he's useful he's Ruddy in appearance and
you could tell he looks different than
his
brothers but the point is made that God
looks on the heart not on the outside
good and that's what we often times fail
to do with other people especially in
this realm is we look on the
outside in the the beginning and and I I
totally agree with you we should be
attracted to the person I think that's
an important par but guess what both of
us in that
relationship this is changing over time
yeah that's true and we're not going to
look the same many years down the road
it's true but if it's the same person
and you grow together you're it's still
going to work still going to work am yes
that was really good points of you guys
so um I think God again would have let's
say we would have married um there were
some issues I guess God could still
blessed it but it would have more
struggle you know um but then so we
actually quit working together during
that time and um I remember I was still
running that health food store and I
still had a desire you know for for
marriage but I saw in the same time that
God was working over those experiences
and years that I saw the focus of
marriage was not that strong anymore I
still had the desire but it was not
determined um or you know was not yeah
you let go yes exactly yeah it's a good
way to say it and um what was really
nice in the same time that also while
God was introducing me more into like
his principles that we will talk about
now um that I also made that that that I
want to say like final victory over
masturbation during that time which was
very important and again people can
watch that that testimony here on your
channel and then I got a message I was
cleaning up in the store in the evening
got a message on my Facebook page for uh
from our store and there was this young
lady and she liked the store on Facebook
and then I looked her up um and then I
saw that she's from the Netherlands and
I was a little bit like that's that's
weird why does somebody from the
Netherlands you know you know like the
store so I contacted her with my private
account we got in touch her first
question was who are you anyway you know
so I said you know I'm I'm the guy from
that store you know and I was not when I
saw her picture I was not like oh maybe
she's my wife you know I was just very
curious why somebody from the
Netherlands contacted um the store so we
got in touch and then while we were
talking where we're texting we figured
out both of us that we both sday
Adventists uh we figured out that like
we talked a little bit chat a little bit
like about our lifestyle you know that
we have both plan-based things like this
then were that we're both kind of in
Mission work and I was like that's
that's curious you know so and um then I
we made an appointment to talk on Skype
so a few days later then um put my
laptop there and and put it up here and
then I expected her to see her the first
time at least on the
screen and um when I opened up and
started Skype camera
off her camera was off was just black my
camera was on I started talk or we
started talk with each other and then I
was thinking maybe she will turn on the
camera soon but she didn't for 2 hours
so but you know she was so shy was so
shy because of um her background which
is a specific story for by
itself um but um I just love to talk to
her was just nice to and I think that
God put it on purpose because I was
before like you know just looking on on
you know the outside and though she's of
course also beautiful woman but I was
not distracted by it so I was just
listening to her voice and we had good
conversation
and while we were sharing a little bit
more about our
background um she was like in one
situation like a um um machine gun she
was just sharing with me her upbringing
and her um just recently experiences
which was like she was brought up in a
situation that she had a lot of um demon
attacks then she she was not Adventist
by birth so she was introduced in the
the faith and became Adventist and then
she married actually another Adventist
but she was divorced after one year that
guy went back to the world unfortunately
and so she was like okay I tell him
immediately you know all these bad
things in my life and then he will hang
up anyway so she was like like this but
I was not by God's grace I was not
shocked by it so I had peace I just like
to talk with her and then some things
like in our first longer conversation we
really checked on each other other and
also after the time we which I believe
is very important when it comes to
courtship you know dating is something
that you just again there's not much
guideline to it the outcome is not
really okay what will happen but
courtship which is more kind of biblical
which
means um you really investigate in that
person you really want to figure out who
is that person with the purpose or the
the the goal in mind that you might
marry that person it's not just to have
a fun time know to have maybe you know a
relationship that you have sex with with
each other and which is like we already
mentioned kind of really selfish
actually when you think about it you you
I mean you you let's call a spade a
spade right that's somebody else's wife
if you're not going to marry that person
you're messing around with somebody
else's wife and and I don't think we
look at it like that you know what I
mean yeah we separate that but that's
the reality and it protects you you know
nobody if let's say at a specific point
you you see okay that person person
doesn't fit to me there's no
embarrassment MH because if you decide
you know not to to um engage too much
emotionally and specifically physically
it will really help you to focus on the
person who is the character of that
person what are their goals so we
discussed about you know what we think
about family children how we deal with
money how is our work ethic and of
course what is our faith um and though
we both were on the same page that we
both we s Adventist we really de or
studied deep into that um figuring out
what exactly do you believe as an
Adventist because it doesn't mean you
know because we belong to the same
church that we really believe the same
thing right there's a wide variety of
belief in there yes and I can say this
even this first conversation of course
we had many after that digging deep into
these um very important topics how we
deal with specific things really helped
us to this very day we're now married
since
um 8 years two month and 20 days and a
few hours oh wow you have you are a
better man than I my
friend that's awesome no so uh you know
since um we are married that time it's
not a long time I know you guys married
much longer than I the hard drive full
yes and not not that everything is is
perfect and until this day but I can say
and can testify because we did this time
of Investigation which actually Christ
is doing right now in the most holy
place you know he's investigating his
people to marry them finally you know so
he seeing if is if we're on the same
page if we if we reflecting the Christ
of character sorry if we reflect
Christ's character so and we
investigated in each other and took that
time that I can say even today it really
helped us that we um I don't want to say
that we never have a struggle or a
discussion but we almost every time we
are immediately on the same page so this
is amazing you know but going back a
little bit before we came to that point
is then we became more acquainted I
visited her in the Netherlands the first
time met her parents and this was quite
amazing because when I when I um she was
living at her parents place during that
time again and because it was just few
months after her divorce she first tried
to get you know hold of the husband
again of her ex-husband but he decided
to step away so and um
I arrived there in the Netherlands I
rang the doorbell and then I was
expecting her to see her the first time
in person but she was again so shy she
didn't came to the door her parents came
parents stood there and then we were
looking at each other and I was saying
somewhere I saw you guys before and that
was funny I was 10 years prior to that I
was in the Netherlands attending some
presentations about medical missionary
work and at this meeting I was with that
other Adventist lady that I've told you
before and my wife my today's wife she
was there as well she was not yet
converted but she was at these meetings
but I didn't recognize her though I was
there for two weeks oh wow the whole day
but my focus was just on this other
person you I didn't recognize her W so
but then we realized okay we have met
before actually because her parents were
at these meetings as well so and then I
you know we then finally I saw her and
she was quite shy but we talked with
each other spent a nice weekend went
back to Germany then a few months later
I came back to her place then we came to
a point that we we both saw that we on
the same page we liked each other but
both of us had not really like these
feelings you know for each other like
that we were in love or things like this
we liked each other but we both prayed
and this was important we said to God
lord um if you don't show us now clearly
that we should continue you know that
way and go maybe in a relationship then
we will break up because we don't want
that somebody gets hurt so we had our
both we had our experience from the past
with different you know Partners in the
world and uh so we had enough bad
experience to say okay Lord this time
you know we want to do it your way the
next
morning uh we spent time together went
on a walk we read a little bit about uh
in the Bible and then she uh finished up
some some food for me to go home to
Germany I went back and while I was
opening what I don't recommend to do
that but while I was opening the lid of
you know this little box that she did
for me the food inside I opened it up
and on it there was a lot of um like
brues you know this these little Flakes
and I love that stuff she did some
spaghetti with this and I was like oh
man she's the right one you know way to
a man's heart is through his stomach
yeah yeah so but actually what happened
is I started to really miss her for the
first time and then something very
special happened that never happened to
me before I was like in this Hollywood
mode I saw a person and like you see in
these Hollywood movies you know they run
in each other and yeah slow motion there
love and everything is perfect that's
how it happened in my
life so this time though we both didn't
had like feelings to this point and it's
not bad to have feelings and they're
they needful you know yeah but I didn't
had them and she didn't had it so but at
this point I saw that God this time he
was the one who put feelings in my heart
for her and I started to really miss her
I wanted to see her and then I I prayed
about it and I made the decision which
I've learned then Through the Bible it's
important which is the principle of
courtship to in or to to um relate also
to or introduce the parents into the
whole thing amen so because you need
spiritual advice if you have spirit
spiritual parents if you don't have
spiritual parents seek for a person who
is very spiritual who knows the Bible
that will help you know to give you
guideline so I I contacted the or
actually I met the parents at a
different
situation and so I approached them I
told them you know this is my my desire
now to approach your daughter and you
know me by now more so what do you think
and they gave me that blessing we prayed
about it were you
nervous yeah the same night
the same night we were actually at a at
a camp meeting at a at a a meeting there
and I I took her out on a walk I
prepared something on my phone I read it
to her in a specific situation and so
she said yes you know she wants to go in
a relationship with me and then we said
okay how are we doing this now we said
that we continue to study that we did
before already we met so we read a lot
about these principles and we made a
very important decision that I'm so
happy about this today we said that we
of course we will not have sex before
marriage but we also decided and I don't
want to say that this is like a um like
a a firm rule in the Bible I don't want
to say that but we decided and I want to
encourage we decided not to kiss during
the courtship or the the yeah the
courtship maybe then the engagement so
this conversation happened while you
guys were saying let's enter into a
courtship no sex no kissing that came
out that's awesome yeah because we
understood um that even kissing which is
for some people nothing you know what is
kissing in the world you know people
they meet and they go immedately to into
bed kissing is what leads to yeah
exactly so but um I know that you know
kissing is very private yes I I've heard
not by experience but I've heard even
from from
prostitutes which you can go there pay
and do everything with them but they
don't kiss mhm it's almost more sacred
than than the other act that's something
that keep for which is a little bit
weird but for their maybe husband or
friend at home you know so we know
because it it brings you too much to
close together and then you will not be
in that situation that you really see
the person CLE you become too uh
connected with each other and again if
you let's say God showed you on the way
I don't want you to be together there's
no embarrassment it's much easier just
to step away from the situation and
that's fine so we made that decision and
then we became more acquainted with each
other and then there was a situation she
actually from that night from that event
she went back to the Netherlands and
then she started to doubt if if this is
really the right thing to do because of
her situation with the divorce before so
she was praying and she said to God lord
I need to know if teimo and my name is
the short version for Timothy in German
if teimo is the right person I need to
know it from the word of God and she
heard a sermon before where a pastor was
saying you cannot just which is true
randomly open the Bible and put your
finger there and say you know this is
the answer sometimes God is using that
I've had thaten sometimes God is doing
that and it's interesting how God is is
speaking to my wife she he not always
but he often speaks with her through
Bible texts so while she was praying
that she said Lord I need to know it
otherwise I break it up again then God
told told her go to First Corinthians
chapter 4 so she went home she picked up
her Bible and she didn't know what the
verse was saying but she opened up 1
Corinthians chapter 4 um sorry 1
Corinthians chapter 4:1
17 and then again the question was is
teimo the right person Lord I need to
know it from your word and 1 Corinthians
4:1 17 says for this cause have I sent
unto you Timothy who is my beloved Son
and faithful in the Lord who shall bring
you into remembrance of my ways which be
in Christ as I teach everywhere in every
Church wow so she got her answer
beautiful and now and she got confidence
because I can understand she didn't want
to make the same mistake again because
was interesting before she
married that other
person she got a
dream a few days before that she got a
dream where in the dream
um God show her that she will one day
marry a guy from a foreign land she's
from Netherlands I'm from Germany which
has a beard nice she told this to her
first husband and he was like you know
this is this was not from God yeah one
day after they their wedding she found
herself in a situation that she said I
married the wrong person wow and you
don't want to be in that situation yeah
this is horrible again God can work it
out if both work on it right but it's
not easy right so again then God gave
her confidence and God gave us more and
more like evidence leading Us in this
direction seeing that everything kinds
of you know fits with have the same
convictions in faith and how we deal
with life another important principle is
what is our mission together you know
what are we doing together because we
both decided um we want to serve God and
I think there are three questions in
that whole process which are important
which you also find in the book at to
home um to ask yourself the questions
will this relationship bring me more
heavenwards will it bring me you know
closer to Christ and uh will I become
more useful in the work of god wow and
then it says go forward in the fear of
God it doesn't mean that this is already
a you know confirmation a final
confirmation but continue to seek out
God's Will and this is where courtship
is for that you really investigate and
see how God is leading so we came to a
point that I said okay Lord um I see you
know it's quite clear I I would like to
ask her to you know engage and um so I
said Lord um because we talked about
this that if God is leading us into
marriage we want to have a pastor that
we both know personally and have a
friendship with and there was just one
single person in the world a pastor that
we both knew before um we even knew from
each other and that we have like a
friendship to so I called up or I sent a
message to that Pastor and um and he is
a one who he's traveling around the
world all the time and he you do not
really get hold of him so I sent a
message to him I prayed Lord if he is
willing to do the
wedding uh in July of 2016 I made a
specific date um then I know you are
into that and I will ask her so I sent a
message to hours later I got a message
back from him which was already
surprising and he said Timo I will be in
July 2016 in Germany and I can perform
the wedding oh wow and I said okay Lord
I go forward stay heaven but before I
asked her I went again to the parents
first and I tell you honestly if the
parents would have said for whatever
reason I don't want you to go in that
relationship and they if they would have
give me really you know clear evidence
of saying you know Timo for this and
this reason would not be good to marry
our daughter then I would have backed up
MH yeah so but they said okay go ahead
you have our blessings and so I asked
her she agreed you know and then 2006 in
July came the whole year was reigning in
Germany so strongly and then um we said
we want to have a wedding outside you
know in nature so we found this very
amazing place and I want just to go and
show you a picture so this is a picture
of our wedding day and we were thinking
you know maybe we might to rent a tent
because of of rain but God gave us three
or four days for Preparation afterwards
to clean up of beautiful weather and uh
so we had this beautiful wedding where
we invited a lot of our customers even
from the store friends family members
who are not in the faith and then the
moment
came where the Pastor said you know
teimo and anarika they made a specific
commitment they they said we don't kiss
until our wedding day and now is the
moment so you know he prayed upon us and
then he said okay you can you know kiss
her and I we took I mean I took her
hands and she was I I could see you know
she was like a little bit hesitant not
that she didn't want to but she was like
you know everybody she was now you know
everybody was looking first kiss you
want to see it yes our first kiss all
right okay roll
Dr wow so this was our first kiss
beautiful was a special moment and I'm
so happy that specifically as a man that
I made this decision you know sexuality
all these things um is just like
the so quote unquote aftermath you know
which comes afterward and God can lead
in that you know and and and work that
out and I'm so happy that I made this
decision because we were not distracted
you know by making a wrong decision
because we're too close with with each
other and uh I remember one of the
family of her she is not in the faith
she afterwards an an anunt from her she
came towards us she said you know was
such a beautiful wedding great day you
know my wife she was she's an amazing
cook you know and she actually half an
hour before we uh we had the ceremony
she was still in the kitchen she
prepared for 100 people the whole food
because she wanted to give a testimony
what what planned based food can be you
know I have actually tasted your wife's
food for a week a little over a week 10
days it's amazing yeah it's yes your
wife is an excellent cook praise God
yeah praise God about that so she gave
me also very more um great experience
when it comes to that awesome but um so
and then she that end she said you know
was everything was so amazing but that
with the kiss that was a joke right that
you had your first kiss today and we
said no it was not a joke you we we
convicted by that and then we shared
some more principles with her and she
was like oh wow wow know that's
something that you don't hear today yeah
no and so again I can say that until
this very day God gave us a mission
together you know we are constantly like
into into Mission work right now we do
an internship here in the US on the farm
getting more you know into farming and
want to use that for God's work but over
the years we had different things that
we did together and I can really say
again at the end that um I'm so thankful
that though in the beginning both of us
we were not like oh you know this is the
right person and we followed as as good
as we knew the guidelines that God is
giving us in the Bible and I can say
that um I'm just happy that that God you
know brought my wife into my life
because we both love and want to serve
the Lord but in the same time
we have not like I mentioned already
like all these struggles and again we
have sometimes you know not agree on
everything but it's so much easier you
know it's so much more
relaxed and so that that's it's
beautiful and can just encourage people
to study investigate more into the Bible
principles maybe to read that book
Adventist home which will give you more
much more over that that we share today
you know about um yeah if you want to to
follow what what God has in mind for us
and again it's it comes all back to
righteousness by faith to trust God Amen
you know this is such I mean we think
like okay I want to specifically as man
I want to have this person she's so
beautiful she does this or whatever you
know and then we might find out later
that was not the right decision yeah
yeah amen Teo thank you so we hope you
guys were blessed by today's
conversation there's a couple things
that um I think you brought out that are
absolutely amazing ask God he is the
designer of pleasure I think we kind of
we we we kind of always pin that as like
you know oh The Seekers of pleasure
right but God designed these things and
he knows what you need to be happy and
ultimately you're going to be the
happiest with the person that he chooses
y I kind of had that same experience in
my life I know your personal testimony
as well um but this is three guys
sitting here right here that ask that
same similar question to God who do you
want me to be with and I believe that is
what has helped our mares um really
Thrive and like you said I love it it's
not all peaches and Roses right there's
issues and problems but certainly those
things are way easier when you let God
choose that person you make him you know
the third wheel in your or you know the
third string in your relationship and
also I like that you you brought out
that your first connection was through
God like it was not the physical it was
not the look or whatever like this it
was like do we connect on on the level
of God first and then the fact that you
established those things in the in the
beginning of your relationship no
kissing no sex and all that who who has
had that conversation on the first time
that you decide to date right beautiful
but look at the amount of of of joy that
you have when that being the first
moment that you lock lips um we hope you
guys like this video and please like it
give it a thumbs up share it if you can
put a comment or question in the comment
section below we'll put a link to teo's
Ministry you can watch some of his stuff
in German but you'll have to watch it
with English translations but that's
fine um but check out some of the other
videos we've made with Teemo it's
awesome stuff and we hope that you're
inspired this is your first time welcome
and uh we hope that we'll see you again
we'll see you God bless
[Music]